Welcome students to
our last lecture in our
series on the Drugs
Affecting the Autonomic
Nervous System,
the Pharmacology of
Adrenergic Antagonists.
Dr. Goldstein speaking.
Please contact me if
you'd like to chat.
Here are our
learning objectives.
I'm sure you're getting
used to them now.
You need to be able
to understand these
pharmacokinetic properties
of the classes and of
the specific drugs that
have STARS on them.
You need to be able to
understand epinephrine
reversal and its
clinical relevance.
You should be able to
talk about, explain,
describe, make figures
of the cardiovascular
effects and reflex
responses that occur
when these various
drugs are administered.
Of course, mechanisms,
mechanisms,
mechanisms, and
their effects.
Relate the mechanisms
of adverse effects
and potential drug
interactions of the
individual agents to
their cautions and
contraindications for
use. This is a clinical
application of the
pharmacology concepts.
Here are the
preparation materials,
should you wish
to use them.
The practice questions
are required.
ScholarRxBricks, I'm sure
you have found by now,
can be very helpful.
Preparation materials
links and our key
points. I'm not
going to go over each
and every one of these.
It's here to give
you sort of a preview
into the lecture.
You can use it as a
study aid. I recommend
that you make your
own tables and
figures and concept
maps and and however
you can make your
studying efficient.
Lots of key points
boiled down here for you.
This is a little
concept map put
together and published
in the Goodman
and Gilman text to
show you how these
are separated into
their classes.
Adrenergic
antagonists inhibit
the interaction
of endogenous
norepinephrine
and epinephrine.
That's the point.
So they are inhibiting
the sympathetic
effects of these
neurotransmitters.
and they will also
inhibit the effects
of sympathetic
sympathomimetic
drugs when administered
prior to them.
We will talk about
drugs that are non
-selective and block
both alpha 1 and
alpha 2 adrenergic
receptors and we're
going to talk about
epinephrine reversal.
Alpha blockers block
the vasopressor
effects of epinephrine
and narepinephrine.
When we talk about
alpha blockers we have
to think about what's
going to happen
when we block those
alpha receptors so we
need to know what they
do physiologically
so on vascular smooth
muscle they cause
vasoconstriction so
let's take this apart.
The alpha-1 receptors
cause vasoconstrictions
throughout the vascular
system, and they
also cause constriction
of visceral smooth
muscle. Now, with
regard to the alpha-2
receptors, we normally
think about those as
being inhibitory because
they are, after all,
the GI protein-coupled
receptor types. They
are basically widely
expressed on presynaptic
neurons, and by
being on presynaptic
neurons, their normal
functions are suppression
of sympathetic
output and increasing
of vagal tone and
platelet aggregation,
inhibition of the
release of norepinephrine
and acetylcholine from
nerve endings, regulation
of metabolic effects,
which I'm not
going to go into detail
on in this lecture.
But alpha-2
receptors are also
located postsynaptically
directly
on some arteries
and veins.
Activation of these
postsynaptic alpha-2
receptors on
vasculature will lead to
contraction of these
vessels, vasoconstriction.
The effect is less
pronounced than we
see with activation
of alpha 1 receptors.
Now these non selective
alpha blockers
are blocking both
alpha 1 and alpha 2.
Blocking alpha 1
clearly is going to
prevent sympathetic
induced vasoconstriction
so lead to
vasodilation, blocking
alpha-2 receptors is
going to block all
of these presynaptic
effects and this
postsynaptic
vasoconstrictive effect.
So the non-selective
alpha blockers will
cause widespread
vascular relaxation,
vasodilation, And it
will also block the
presynaptic effects
so that norepinephrine
and acetylcholine are
not inhibited from
being released, not
regulated, I should
say, and in fact
can be released. And
if we think about the
various effects on
both the alpha-1 and
alpha-2 receptors,
we can more easily
understand the actions
of these non-selective
alpha blockers.
Class effects,
epinephrine reversal,
which I'll go
into in detail.
Cardiovascular effects,
direct relaxation
of arterial urinary
venous. stone.
That will decrease
peripheral
vascular resistance,
decrease blood
pressure. That's
the point of them.
So they are used for the
treatment of
hypertension.
They were developed
for the treatment of
chronic primary hypertension.
They are used as
add-on agents. They are
not first-line. Well
I'll talk more about
that later. And I
mentioned that they block
alpha-1 receptors on
visceral smooth muscle,
which is used to
therapeutic advantage
for relaxation of the
smooth muscle tone in
the prostate and bladder
neck, and that will
help improve the urinary
symptoms of benign
prostatic hyperplasia.
Right here.
What is the phenomenon
described by
these tracings? So
let's have a look.
Here we have phentolamine
administered.
Here's the initial
blood pressure.
We see a decrease
in blood pressure.
Here's the initial
heart rate,
we see an increase
in heart rate.
Here is epinephrine
being administered into
the vein of this
experimental animal, which
is an anesthetized
dog. And we know that
epinephrine going into
the vein is going to
have this vasoconstrictor
effect as it
activates the alpha
receptors in the vasculature.
And then over time
we see this effect.
And now phentolamine
is given first, so
it will block the
alpha receptors, alpha
-1 and alpha-2 because
it's non-selective.
And then epinephrine
is given and this
is what happens. So
let's talk about it.
This phenomenon is called
epinephrine reversal.
Epinephrine's
presser effect
converts to a
depressor effect.
How is this
happening? Here
we have the chart again.
Here, phentolamine
is administered
prior to the epinephrine.
So the effect, the
pressor effect of
epinephrine is blocked.
Here's initial blood
pressure, and here we
see the blood pressure
is lower. So what
is happening? Well
obviously it's blocking
the alpha receptors.
Think about what epinephrine
does. Epinephrine
will cause vasoconstriction
by activating
alpha receptors, but
it will also cause
vasodilation in the
skeletal smooth muscle by
activating beta 2
receptors located there.
So two things
are happening.
Blocking of the alpha
receptors prevents
epinephrine from
causing contraction
of the smooth muscle
in the vasculature,
and at the same
time, since these are
alpha blockers, they
have no activity
on the beta receptors,
and as a result,
we have unopposed
beta 2 vasodilation.
So we get a depressor
effect. effect.
So let's further
compare this to
phenylephrine to
help you see the net
depressor effect of
epinephrine. This is
before alpha blockade
on both of these,
and phenylephrine is
an alpha-1 selective
vasoconstrictor,
sympathomimetic.
These curves look
very similar as the
drugs are introduced
into the vein, and
they cause activation
of the alpha
receptors in the vasculature
and vasoconstriction.
Now here is an
alpha blocker is
administered
first, and then the
sympathomimetic is
administered afterwards.
We saw on the previous
slide that the
vascular effect
of epinephrine is
blocked here. This
is the alpha effect.
And the beta 2
effect is unopposed.
So we get this
decrease here, and
that's called a net
depressor effect.
Phenyloephrin,
however, having only
alpha-1 activity and
no beta activity,
we see that the alpha
blocker will certainly
block the vasoconstrictive
effect, but
it will not cause the
net depressor effect.
So that's the meaning
of epinephrine reversal.
Very interesting to study
this in the laboratory.
So what is the
clinical application?
Well,
the alpha blockers
are going to be
blocking epinephrine's
effect as well as,
of course,
norepinephrine's effect.
So they're useful for the
management of
blood pressure.
We'll begin with
the non-selective
alpha blockers.
These were developed
first, phenoxybenzamine
actually has
been around since
1952. It was the first
one in the alpha
blockers class and
it found great
therapeutic benefit
for patients with
hypertension and also
for an adrenal tumor
called pheochromocytoma.
Phenthalamine was
developed a little
bit later, so let's
compare these two.
Phenoxybenzamine
is only oral.
Phenthalamine is
only parenteral.
I want to jump to the
fact that phenoxybenzamine
is an irreversible
antagonist, whereas
phenthalamine is
just a competitive
antagonist. The half
-life of phenoxybenzamine
is quite long, the
duration is very long,
whereas the phenolamine
is quite short.
Those are big
differences there
and that will also
guide the therapeutic
application of
these drugs.
So those are the
main clinically
relevant
pharmacokinetic points.
When you are looking
at pharmacokinetic
profiles, it's
important to be able
to pick out what
is clinically
relevant. What is
important for optimizing
therapy in your
individual patient.
This is just a little
chart to remind
you about competitive
antagonists
and irreversible
antagonists. The
competitive antagonists,
we can see the
curves are shifted
towards the right,
but the maximal
effect still occurs,
whereas with an
irreversible antagonist,
the maximal effect
is decreased. And
that's the point with
phenoxybenzamine.
These studies were
done with drugs that
are similar to our
clinically used drugs.
And that's all I'm
going to say about this.
I hope these charts
will help you be able
to visualize the
differences in the
pharmacodynamics of these
drugs and the mechanisms.
So what are the
effects of these non
-selective alpha
blockers? Well, let's
look at the
cardiovascular actions.
Alpha blockade
causes relaxation
of arterial and
venous smooth
muscle, causing
vasodilation.
Vasodilation
decreases peripheral
vascular resistance
and, in fact, will
decrease the main
arterial pressure.
And that, in turn, of
course, as you remember,
will cause reflex
tachycardia. A simple
concept that I know
you're used to by now.
The alpha-2
antagonistic effect
is going to block the
presynaptic alpha
-2 receptors, the
inhibitory effect,
and that will allow
norepinephrine release
from presynaptic
neurons, and
that in turn will
stimulate beta-cardiac
receptors, which
will contribute to
the tachycardia.
The urinary retention
therapeutic use
relaxes the smooth
muscle of the
prostate and bladder
neck and that is going
to relieve the
urinary symptoms of
benign prostatic
hyperplasia as I
mentioned before and
it bears repeating.
Phenoxybenzamine
is used now mainly
for the presurgical
management
of the hypertension
and sweating
associated with
pheochromocytoma.
Pheochromocytoma is
a rare tumor of the
adrenal glands. It's
estimated at 0.8 per
100,000 person years,
which may be an
underestimation. But
nonetheless, this is a
basic concept you need
to know, and you may
actually be faced
with a person who's
presenting with hypertension,
and pheochromocytoma
may be on your
differential list.
Treatment of
urinary symptoms.
Phentolamine,
intraoperative hemodynamic
instability. We have
other drugs also for this,
but phyntalamine may
still be an option.
And you recall that
it's got a rapid onset,
rapid offset, and
it's very effective.
So those
characteristics are what
make it so suitable
for intraoperative
hemodynamic
instability management.
Also, some pressor
agents, as we mentioned
in those lectures,
can leak out of the
venous access and
could lead to necrosis
of the tissues at
that area. So by
blocking the alpha
receptors in that area,
by administering
phenolamine by infiltration,
that can be used
as a treatment for
the extravasation of
the pressor agent.
And it also has a
dental application where
it's infiltrated
into the area in the
mouth where the anesthetic
was administered.
Some local anesthetics
are given with
epinephrine to
kind of hold it in
place, hold that
local anesthetic in
place for a little
bit longer because
the epinephrine is
causing vasoconstriction
right there in
that local area.
So the phantolamine
has developed
for this dental purpose.
Excuse me, push
strong button.
Vascular effects.
Now, adverse effects.
We need to be
thinking about this.
Orthostatic hypotension.
What is that?
That occurs when a
patient who is susceptible
to this effect rises
from a lying down
position to a sitting
or standing position.
when we do that and we
are in a good healthy
state our blood
pressure goes up and
it prevents the and it
pushes blood back to
the heart so it
increases the cardiac
output and that increases
the blood to the
brain and we feel
fine but when a person
has orthostatic
hypotension either because
he's got a neurologic
condition, or because
of alpha blockade
on those veins when
rising to the standing
position, there is
no vasoconstriction
because it's blocked.
And as a result,
there is a decrease in
the cardiac output
because that blood
is not being pushed
back to the heart,
and that can cause a
decrease of blood to
the brain, and that
can cause syncope,
fainting.
Fainting causes falling,
falling can cause injury.
Additionally,
we talked about
the fact that we
get a decrease
in mean arterial
pressure,
which is going to cause
a reflex tachycardia
to try and push
that pressure up.
Now I know you haven't
learned about the
cardiovascular system
yet and all of these
reflexes. These are
pretty straightforward
concepts that you
will be able to
grasp at this time
even though you haven't
had a full cardiovascular
lecture yet.
It's just a matter
of we're blocking the
alpha receptors in the
veins and arteries,
and that's going
to decrease the
blood pressure, and
if the mean arterial
blood pressure drops,
especially rapidly,
then we have systems
in our body to
overcome that, to
try and bring us back
to homeostasis, to
try and bring that
blood pressure back
up. And that is
tachycardia, increase
in the heart rate to
increase the cardiac
output, to increase
the blood pressure.
Simple as that.
Now, non-vascular
effects, these drugs
do cross the blood
-brain barrier, so it
can cause some sedation
and depression.
They do block the
midriatic effect of
alpha receptors
in the iris smooth
muscle, and as a result
you're going to get
unopposed parasympathetic
activation.
So that causes meiosis.
Nasal stuffiness
because of the
vasodilation in the nose,
GI tract motility
because we're
blocking the alpha
receptors in the gut,
and impaired or
retrograde ejaculation
because of the block
of the alpha receptors.
Drug interactions.
Well, other drugs
that cause the
same effect, other
drugs that cause
opposite effects.
The drugs that cause
the same effects,
in other words, other
antihypertensive
drugs, these are
alpha blockers or add
-ons to them to increase
the antihypertensive
effect in patients
who have not
reached their blood
pressure goals by
using the first line
combination agents.
And then there are
other drugs that are
not used for blood
pressure, but they have
blood pressure lowering
effects. So if we
add them to those
drugs, that's going to
enhance blood pressure
lowering, which may
not be beneficial. Now
I want to point out
to you, because I'm
sure you're thinking,
well, I don't know
anything about any
of those drugs. Do
I have to memorize
them? And the answer
is right down here.
No, you don't
have to answer.
You don't have to
memorize drugs that
we haven't learned
about yet. You do
need to understand
the mechanisms when
the mechanisms are
described to you.
Now, of course,
there are exceptions.
Actually, no exceptions.
What I want to
point out is that these
drugs with the check
marks are included
in our autonomic
nervous system lectures.
So you do need to
remember about
vasopressors and their
mechanisms, amphetamines
and their mechanisms,
and beta blockers
and their mechanisms.
So let's talk about
the alpha-1 selective
drugs. These have
far more clinical
application in the
management of blood
pressure and the
urinary symptoms of BPH.
I put a star on the
first ones in each group.
Perazicin has the
star on it. It
is the prototype
and representative
of all of the
class effects.
These two, terazicin
and doxazicin, are
the ones that are
actually used much more
frequently in
clinical practice. But
they have the same
effects. The only
difference really is
their pharmacokinetics.
All of these are
used in clinical
practice, but they
have the same mechanism
and their effects
are all very similar.
And an alpha-2
selective drug,
this is called Yohimbine.
It has in the past
been available by
prescription many,
many decades ago. It is
frequently found in
botanical products.
Alpha-1 selective
agents have far more
affinity for the
alpha-1 receptors,
so much so that really
they have very little
effect on blocking
the alpha-2 receptors.
The quinazolanes,
which is the
prazosin group,
are selective alpha
-1 blockers, but
they do block all
of the subtypes.
Tamsulosin,
which is for BPH,
has greater affinity
for the alpha-1a and
alpha-1d, but it is
the alpha-1a that is
of clinical interest
because those are
found to be expressed
on the prostate smooth
muscle and bladder
neck smooth muscle.
So what are
they used for?
Well,
hypertension. Add
-on, not first line.
In fact, it's fourth,
maybe fifth line.
And why? Why is
this? If they're so
effective, I mean really,
wouldn't we want to
use them sooner than
fourth or fifth line?
The reason is because
a particularly
important clinical
study called the ALHAT
study found that the
using doxazosin was more
the patients who were
on doxazosin were
had a greater increase
in morbidity and
mortality so this is
why they are have found
their way to farther
down on the list.
So what do they do?
Relax arterial and
be in a smooth
muscle, decrease total
peripheral resistance,
decrease preload,
afterload. Preload,
that means the drug
is going into the
atria and eventually
finds its way into
the ventricles and
that's the preload
point right there.
Afterload is the pressure
against the aortic
vasculature. So
that's afterload, it
comes after the blood
leaves the ventricles.
And the
ventricles have to
push against
that pressure.
BPH, I've said
this now, I think
this is the fourth
or fifth time,
relief of the
urinary symptoms.
Now, Tamsulosin,
which is the one that
has a greater affinity
for 1A than the
1B type of alpha
receptors, does have
less pronounced effect
on blood pressure,
and it is not used
for blood pressure.
It can still
cause orthostatic
hypotension, though.
Speaking of which,
First dose effect.
This is an
important concept.
When patients are
started on the alpha
blocker, even
though it's an add
-on, their pressure
tends to be high.
And when they take
that first dose
and rise from a
lying down position
to a sitting or
standing position,
there can be
quite a drop in
blood pressure
that can lead to
the syncope. It
can be severe.
The patient can experience
the palpitations
and tachycardia.
Tachycardia is important
because it puts the
stress on the heart.
It increases what they
call the work of the
heart, which increases
oxygen consumption.
And in patients who
have coronary artery
disease, that can
cause an angina attack.
The first dose effect,
the patient can
experience dizziness,
lightheadedness,
and syncope or
fainting, falling.
So how is this managed?
Just because there
are adverse effects
doesn't mean we don't
try and mitigate them.
We do, of course.
So, if the patient
takes it at bedtime,
they will be sleeping
during the peak blood
levels, and in the
morning, the blood
levels will be much
lower. Nonetheless, when
they get out of
bed, they need to be
cautioned about this
potential for the signs
and symptoms of
orthostatic hypotension.
The other thing
is it's called
the first dose
effect, but it
may occur for
several doses.
So patients should
be advised to
take the first
dose at bedtime,
take it every day.
If it's a once
-a-day drug, take
it at bedtime.
Prazosin is
taken more often,
which is one reason
why it's not used
so much. it's a patient
adherence issue.
When they're
taking it strictly
for BPH, such as
with Tamsulosin,
then they still
need to be cautioned
about this effect. Now
another strange thing
that was unanticipated
but discovered
in post-marketing
surveys is something
called intraoperative
floppy iris syndrome,
which of course
received an acronym.
It occurs during
cataract surgery. The
ophthalmologists were
finding that when
patients who had
been on an alpha
blocker, mainly
tamsulosin, this was first
observed with this
drug, were having
difficulties with
the cataract surgery
because of this
floppy iris syndrome.
They now have strategies
for managing it.
Stopping the drug in
advance doesn't help.
And the reason is
because it causes
relaxation in the
iris dilator muscle.
Non-vascular
adverse effects,
sedation,
depression, meiosis,
meiosis because
of the alpha
blockade, preventing
medriasis,
nasal stuffiness
because of the
vasodilation in
the nasal mucosa.
It kind of blocks
up the nares.
Increased GI motility.
And now, Tamsulosin has a
specific one. It's
got a sulfonamide
moiety on it.
So patients,
this is out of an
excess of caution.
Patients who have
a sulfonamide
allergy should not
receive Tamsulosin.
Patients who did
report a sulfonamide
allergy were not included,
they were excluded
from the clinical
trials with Tamsulosin.
Now Yohimbine or
Yohimbibark you may see on
the label. Competitive
alpha 2 selective
adrenergic receptor
antagonist. It has central
effects, it crosses the
blood-brain barrier.
It increases the blood
pressure, increases
the heart rate as
you would anticipate.
It enhances
motor activity.
It causes tremors.
It is believed to be
a ****** stimulant.
It has stimulating
effect on the mood.
The clinical trials
for increasing ******
and improving erectile
dysfunction are
not very well controlled,
so we can't really
say with certainty
what the clinical
effects of Yohanbeam
are as an aphrodisiac.
As expected, tachycardia,
hypertension,
nausea, vomiting,
anorexia,
salivation, which
is cholinergic
M3, but it's
still sympathetic.
This is an endocrine
action in the pituitary.
Tremors, sweating,
headache,
agitation, anxiety,
irritability.
And it's over
-the-counter.
It's not FDA-approved.
Anything over-the
-counter is not rigorously
analyzed by the FDA
because that's just
the way the rules
are so patients take
it on their own
so if a patient is
presenting with these
this constellation
of effects of
complaints would be good
to ask if they're
taking any botanicals
as well as other
drugs of course
and put it on your
differential list
some questions now I
invite you to pause
your computer and think
about these how does
the concept of epinephrine
reversal explain
antihypertensive actions
of alpha blockers
what is the reason and
of course mechanism
for advising patients
to take the first dose
of a selective alpha
blocker at bedtime.
And finally, selective
inhibition of which
adrenergic receptor
type, listed here,
leads to this
constellation of effects.
Tachycardia,
hypertension, nausea,
vomiting, anorexia,
salivation,
tremors, diaphoresis,
headache,
agitation, anxiety,
irritability.
And what's the
name of the drug?
So, I'm figuring
you're back now
and you've thought
of these and maybe
you look back on
the PowerPoint.
Blocking vascular alpha
adrenergic receptors
prevents Epi's
vasoconstrictive
actions leading to
vasodilation, and its
beta-2 mediated
vasodilation is unopposed,
contributing to the
antidepressive actions
of the alpha blockers,
causing a net
net depressor effect.
What is, okay, the next
one, the first dose
or first few doses
may cause orthostatic
hypotension because
when rising from a
lying down to upright
position, reflex
vasoconstriction is
blocked. And finally, the
drug, of course, is
Yohimbine, a selective
alpha-2 adrenergic
receptor blocker that
can potentially cause
all of these effects.
Dose-related, dose
-related, dose-related.
Moving now to the beta
receptor antagonists.
Everybody always calls
them beta blockers.
beta blockers. That's
what we're talking about.
And there are quite a
bunch of them. You may
have noticed that on
that little mind map
at the beginning
underneath the beta blocker
large category.
They come, the so
-called classical non
-selective beta
blockers, so beta 1
and beta 2, the
beta 1 selected beta
blockers, which at
high doses lose their
selectivity, and
then there are the
various types with
additional actions.
I've put stars
on this chart.
These are the
two that at this
time is all you
need to remember.
Later on,
you'll be asked
to understand and
describe, be able to
explain all of these
other features. I
have them here for
context. I don't want
you to think that
if I just put these
top two, that's all
there is. It isn't.
So the various
beta blockers will
have two or maybe
three of these
actions, they don't
have all of them.
So they are either
competitive antagonists
and some of them
have been found to
be inverse agonists.
I'm just bringing
that up. The point is
the inverse agonist
has the same effects
as the competitive
antagonist. so I
want you to remember
the competitive
antagonist and the non
-selective versus the
selective effects,
that's it.
Okay, we have
another group of
tracings here
demonstrating an effect.
Here we have
administration
of epinephrine alone.
This is cardiac
contractile force,
so the force of
contraction on the
atria and the ventricles.
We see a spike
as epinephrine
causes that increase
in force, causes
that contraction.
We have the
effect on arterial
pressure, which
you saw before.
And we have our
increase in our
heart rate. We know
that epinephrine
causes all these effects.
Here propranolol,
which is the prototype
of this group, is
administered, and then
after that epinephrine
is administered.
So propranolol blocks
beta-1 and beta-2.
So the contractile
force is blocked by
blocking the beta
-1, beta-2 receptors.
The arterial pressure
is not blocked because
the alpha receptors
are not blocked.
And the heart
rate again that is
a beta 1 effect.
This is blocked.
So beta blockers
block the cardiac
effects but not the
arterial effects.
But by decreasing
the force of
contraction, decreasing
the heart rate,
beta blockers are
going to decrease the
cardiac output,
in other words the
amount of blood that's
being pushed out of
the left ventricle
in a unit of time.
So that will increase
and that, sorry
it's going to decrease
that, so that will
in turn decrease
the blood pressure.
So that's how beta
blockers work.
And we have it
laid out here.
I put in the box
the takeaway.
This is the big
picture idea with beta
blockers. They slow
the heart rate,
they slow the rate
of conduction through
the atrial
ventricular node, and
they decrease the
force of contraction.
That will decrease
the cardiac output.
which decreases
the blood pressure.
And here are
the mechanisms.
It has a negative
chronotropic effect,
in other words,
it slows the sinus
rate. The sinoatrial
node generates
the electrical
signals that set the
normal rhythm and
rate of the heart.
So that's slowed down.
It decreases spontaneous
rate of depolarization
of ectopic pacemakers.
Now this is
the reason for its
antiarrhythmic effect.
It reduces the
contractility and that's
called negative
inotropic effect.
It slows the
conduction in the atria
and the AV node and
that will increase
the PR interval
on the ECG, which
I have a picture
of that for you.
And it will increase
the functional
refractory period
in the AV node
because it is slowing
the conduction.
That's the point of it.
So those are
the mechanisms.
This is the takeaway.
Now, we're talking
about the non-selective
ones. You're probably
thinking, well,
if we block beta 2
receptors, isn't Isn't
that going to block
the beta-2 vasodilatory
effect in the skeletal
muscle, and that
would be a great way
to think about it.
So yes, it does at
first, at first,
but that is a
short-lived thing.
Long term, the
non-selective beta
blocker, the total
peripheral resistance
returns to the initial
value and it can
even decrease
in patients with
hypertension because
we're getting a reset.
So that's the
idea with the non
-selective beta blockers
being effective in
the management
of elevated blood
pressure, hypertension.
Now the renin
-angiotensin system,
this is probably
something you remember
from somewhere.
This is a hormonal
system. It's much slower
to respond to changes
in blood pressure,
but it does respond,
and it's intended
to bring us back
to homeostasis, and
that occurs when the
blood pressure drops.
When blood pressure
drops, then renin is
released, and renin
causes eventually the
synthesis of angiotensin
II, which is a
powerful systemic
vasoconstrictor. So
that's good when our
blood pressure drops
and we need this
vasoconstrictive effect.
Now, renin release
is also stimulated by
beta 1. So when there
is a sympathetic
increase in tone,
that will stimulate
the cardiac effects,
that will cause the
vasoconstriction, and
that will stimulate
renin release through
beta 1. So when we
block beta 1, we are
blocking that sympathetic
stimulated release
of renin. Now, renin
can be released by
other ways, but we're
talking about the
sympathetic effect causing
the release of renin,
which is blocked by
the beta blockers.
That's it.
The takeaway,
the mechanisms,
and don't forget
about those
renin release
in the kidney.
This is a kidney effect.
Here are the
pictures. This is
just a reminder
of the sympathetic
innovation of the heart.
And that's with
all of these here.
You can see the
paravertebral ganglia.
And here we have
our vagal effect.
So, the vagus will
decrease the rate of
sinoatrial firing,
so decrease heart
rate, decrease speed
of conduction through
the atrioventricular
node, and also
decrease the force
of contraction in the
atria. It's got very
little innervation
of the ventricular
parts of the heart.
Here we have
our sinoatrial
node, here we
have our AV node,
left atrium,
right atrium, left
ventricle,
right ventricle.
And this whole
thing is indicating
the electricity
running through the
conduction system.
Here's are EKG, this
is a normal EKG
tracing or just one
little piece of
it, representation.
P-wave is in the front.
P-wave is,
this bump here
indicates the
depolarization
of the atria,
atrial contraction.
So that gets slowed by
use of a beta blocker.
Therapeutic uses. I
put some light colors
on this to indicate,
first of all, these
are the main
cardiovascular effects that
we think about with
the beta blockers.
These are a couple of
other therapeutic uses
that are managed because
of the cardiovascular
effects of beta
blockers. And these are
the non-cardiovascular
uses of beta blockers.
So hypertension,
decreased cardiac output,
blood pressure,
decreased renin release.
Angina pectoris, this
is chest pain, in
patients who have
coronary artery disease.
By decreasing
the work of the
heart, decreasing
the heart rate
conduction and
contraction,
force of contraction,
that's going to decrease
oxygen consumption.
So they're very useful
for the management
of exertional angina
pectoris. Acute myocardial
infarction. This is
based on excellent
clinical studies showing
the improvement in
morbidity and mortality
when a beta blocker is
given early in acute
myocardial infarction.
Congestive heart failure,
again, based on excellent
clinical studies
showing a benefit in
morbidity and mortality,
has to be done very
carefully and only
in patients with
compensated heart failure.
Certain types.
Arrhythmias, they are
antiarrhythmic for
the treatment of
various arrhythmias.
hyperthyroidism this
is what happens with
when people have
consistently elevated levels
of thyroid various
metabolic things occur
and one of them is an
upregulation of cardiac
beta receptors so
there are more beta
receptors expressed
on cardiac tissues and
this can result in
tachycardia palpitations,
this kind of tremor
feeling, tremulousness,
anxiety. So use of
beta blockers is
recommended for management
of these symptoms.
Esophageal varices,
these are varicose veins
in the esophagus as
a result of hepatic
cirrhosis. And hepatic
cirrhosis causes an
increase in portal
hypertension. So certain
of the beta blockers
have been shown to
decrease the portal
hypertension and
importantly decrease the
incidence of bleeding
from these varicose
veins and decrease
mortality in patients
with hepatic cirrhosis.
Glaucoma, this is
an effect on the
ciliary body which
forms the aqueous humor.
So using our
beta blocker will
decrease aqueous
humor formation, which
will decrease the
pressure in the eye.
Migraine prophylaxis,
performance anxiety.
This doesn't work
for everybody, but
for people that it
does work for, they
take it regularly
to help reduce the
intensity and frequency
of the migraines.
Stage fright, performance
anxiety, getting
the palpitations
and the shakiness,
so giving a beta
blocker an hour or
so before the
performance can reduce
these somatic
symptoms of anxiety.
Adverse effects,
fortunately
most of them are minor.
bradycardia can
occur, and so
that needs to
be monitored.
Bronchospasm, this is
the beta-2 block, so
we're talking about
the non-selective, and
don't forget, higher
doses of the beta-1
selective tend to lose
their selectivity.
So anybody with a
obstructive disease in
which bronchospasm can
reduce their ability
to breathe like asthma,
COPD, the recommendation
is to avoid the
non-selective beta
blockers, and maybe beta
blockers in general.
Also, blocking
beta 2 can mask the
symptoms of
hypoglycemia, and these
symptoms are
tachycardia, shakiness,
anxiety. So in patients
who are prone to
hypoglycemia, which would
be insulin-dependent
patients, patients
taking certain and
type 2 diabetes
patients taking certain
hypoglycemic agents are
especially likely to
develop to have these
symptoms masked and
as a result they won't
notice the hypoglycemia
and the hypoglycemia
can be dangerous.
Additionally, blocking
beta 2 can inhibit
the reflex hepatic
production of glucose
which would then
raise blood sugar. So
these two things
masking and preventing
the production of
glucose lipid the hepatic
production of
glucose. Some lipid
abnormalities are
always mentioned in the
literature. So it's a
matter of monitoring.
And these CNS features
have been described
ever since the very
first beta blocker was
developed decades ago.
Fatigue, depression,
****** dysfunction,
some other CNS effects.
These have been
examined in studies
over these many years.
The studies tend
to be poor, so
this is going to be
a patient-specific
effect. Many patients
tolerate beta
blockers very well.
Now, slow withdrawal.
Slow.
Slow tapering.
Because going back to
are basic pharmacodynamic
concepts. When a
patient, when a person
is taking a drug that
blocks receptors over
time, chronically over
time, then the tissue
that is subject to
these blocked receptors
is going to express
more of these receptors.
So abrupt withdrawal
of of the drug
can lead, of the
beta blocker,
can lead to
hypertensive rebound.
We call that rebound
hypertension.
Severe hypertension,
and if the
patient has coronary
artery disease,
they can suffer
chest pain,
possibly a myocardial
infarction,
possibly an arrhythmia,
possibly a risk of
increased risk of sudden
death and this is
due to the super
sensitivity that occurred
because of this adaptive
upregulation of
the beta receptors
mitigation taper the
dose of beta blocker over
several weeks we
talked about this also
with clonidine and if
the two are used together
the beta blocker
must come off first,
BB first, so that the
alpha receptors are
not unopposed. If the
clonidine comes off
first, then the alpha
receptors are exposed,
and we know beta blockers
don't block those.
contraindications you
can anticipate them
asthma hypersensitivity
of course with
everything all right
pregnancy what's the
deal with that the
drugs do cross the
placenta other
antihypertensive agents are
preferred and there
is one exception and
this is libetalol
which is used for the
management of chronic
hypertension and also
acute hypertension in
the pregnant patient.
I do not have a
star on on it this
time when we talk about
anti hypertensives.
I will have a star
on it at that point.
Drug interactions you
could anticipate them.
Other anti
hypertensive drugs.
Calcium channel
blockers could increase
the risk of heart
block. I'm not going
into that detail for
this lecture. It is a
very important detail
for a later time.
They are
metabolized by CYPs.
Non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory
drugs like
naproxen, Aleve,
like ibuprofen
will increase sodium
and water retention
because that's
just what they do.
and that can
attenuate the
antihypertensive effect.
And other drugs
that increase
or decrease
blood pressure.
So that's it
in a nutshell.
Some questions.
How do the beta blockers
inhibitory effects
on cardiac cells
reduce blood pressure?
What is the
mechanistic thread that
connects all the
therapeutic uses of the beta
blockers? How does
the mechanism of
action describe the
mechanisms of adverse
effects associated
with beta blockers?
So I invite you
to pause your
videos and give
it some thought.
Assuming you're back now,
the first one is beta
blockers decrease
cardiac output by decreasing
heart rate, slowing
the rate of conduction
through the AV node,
and decreasing the
force of contraction.
And I should
put on here too,
because I forgot,
beta 1 block
blocks renin release.
Beta blockers inhibit
the stimulating
effects of the
sympathetic
nervous system on
beta adrenergic
receptors. It's
as simple as that.
So, it's various
therapeutic uses
are all related
to blocking the
stimulating effects
of the sympathetic
nervous system on
the beta receptors.
Adverse effects,
they can all cause
bradycardia in patients
who are particularly
susceptible to it.
of course they're
slowing the heart
rate. Bradycardia
is a deep slowing
of the heart rate.
There are different
definitions of it. Some
say less than 60,
some say less than 40,
40 or so. So it depends
on the definition.
But they all can
potentially cause
bradycardia because
that's what they do.
Blocking the beta
-2 receptors can
exacerbate lung
disease, asthma, COPD,
and potentiate or mask
systems of hypoglycemia.
And the drugs propranolol
and metoprolol,
or metoprolol, both
pronunciations are used.
Propranolol is
non-selective,
metoprolol is beta
-1 selective, so
that's why these
two are chosen.
The clinically relevant
pharmacokinetic
properties are
oral, they're both
oral, but metoprolol
can be given IV
in case we need too
rapidly, or not too
rapidly, to bring
down the blood
pressure in a very
hypertensive patient.
They cross the
blood-brain
barrier, both of them,
we see CYPs involved,
but metoprolol here
we have CYP2D6. So
remember our
pharmacogenomics, which I'm
not going to go into
now, just you might
want to review that
and remember CYP2D6.
the bioavailability
is adequate it happens
with the immediate
release should be taken
on an empty stomach
in order to get blood
the consistent blood
levels with each dose
it's only 25 percent
if taken with protein
rich foods it's higher
and therefore that's
why the recommendation
of the the empty
stomach, just to have
consistent blood levels.
Propranolol, three
to six hours.
Metoprolol,
around four hours.
Longer and poor
metabolizers.
Both of these come in
extended-release
formulations
so that they're
much more convenient
for the patient
and help to improve
adherence to the
drug therapy.
and finally here
is that that
little chart again
look at all of
these various drugs
underneath the
big headings which
is why i'm there's
i absolutely you
don't need to memorize
all of these not
necessary when you
get into to your
clinical rotations
you look them up
you should know your
pharmacology
well enough to
read a monograph
and quickly
understand what
it's telling you.
Briefly, we have
our alpha blockers,
relaxing vascular smooth
muscle and decreasing
peripheral vascular
resistant. We
talked about epinephrine
reversal as being
a predictable effect
of alpha blockade.
We talked about
our beta blockers,
reducing heart rate,
conduction velocity,
force of contraction,
and cardiac output.
They both reduce blood
pressure by their
various mechanisms.
They're sometimes put
together also because
they have these
two mechanisms that
do work well together.
Non-selective
alpha blockers are
phenoxybenzamine
and phenolamine.
Phenoxybenzamine is
used primarily for the
presurgical management
of pheochromocytoma.
Surgery is curative
for pheochromocytoma.
Phantolamine is
rapid-acting, short
-term use,
intraoperative, severe
hypertension. It's
also used for reversal
of extravasation
of pressor agents
and for reversal
of local anesthesia
containing epinephrine
for dental use.
Alpha blockers are add-on
agents, beta
blockers, are also
add-on agents
for hypertension.
Alpha blockers are
used for managing
urinary symptoms
of BPH. Alpha
blockers causes
first-dose effect,
intraoperative
floppy iris syndrome,
meiosis, nasal
stuffiness, and
impaired or retrograde
ejaculation.
Beta blockers have
prominence effect in the
heart, decreasing
chronotropy, inotropy,
and suppressing renin
release from specialized
cells in the kidney.
These are called
juxtaglomerular cells
because they're next
to the glomerulus at
the afferent renal
arteriole, the one going
into the glomerulus.
We've got a
whole bunch of
beta blockers
that are used.
Treatment of a number
of cardiovascular
diseases, arrhythmias,
effort angina,
acute myocardial
infarction, congestive
heart failure, add
-on hypertension.
So hypothyroidism,
esophageal
varices, migraine
prophylaxis,
stage fright.
Adverse effects,
bronchospasm,
bradycardia,
decreased cardiac
output, which is actually
their blood pressure
lowering effect, but
that can be harmful
in certain patients.
hypoglycemic
effects, masking
hypoglycemia, lipid
abnormalities,
depression, fatigue,
****** dysfunction have
been reported.
So that's it.
Pretty straightforward.
You can put this
all on a couple of
figures on one
page to help you
be more efficient
in your studying.
And that concludes
includes our whole
series on the
pharmacology of drugs
affecting the autonomic
nervous system.